members of the Trump administration will
go to Capitol Hill today to testify
about the president's proposed budget
it faces pushback from Democrats and
some Republicans Congress ultimately
sets the budget some lawmakers are
concerned about more than eight hundred
billion dollars in proposed cuts over
the next decade to Medicaid food
assistance and health insurance for
low-income children budget director Mick
Mulvaney said the reductions will help
make sure taxpayer money is not wasted
we are not kicking anybody off of any
program who really needs it that's not
we have plenty of money in this country
to take care of the people who need help
okay and we will do that we don't have
enough money to take care of people
everybody who doesn't need help
the president's proposal does protect
Social Security and Medicare
how Governor John Kasich has experienced
dealing with the nation's budget as a
congressman he chaired the House Budget
Committee he oversaw the 1995 government
shutdown and a balanced federal budget
the governor is the author of the book
two paths America divided our United
Governor Kasich welcome back thanks
charlie what impact will this budget as
presented have on the state of Ohio
would it be significant Charlie but this
isn't going to pass you know presidents
end up budgets and then the Congress
fiddles around to things to keep in mind
number one we have a program in Ohio
where we're saying to people we will
help you but then we need you to assume
personal responsibility we'll help you
to overcome your problems the problem
here is that you can't just take stuff
away when people need to be healthy they
need to be fed you know so it's not just
a one-way street it has to be both ways
so the other thing is the Congress will
play around with this thing we don't
know where end up but here's a problem
with debt if they don't come to grips
with debt its rising higher and higher
as a percentage of our economy when that
goes up job opportunities go down and
when debt comes down job opportunities
go up that's why it's important we
restructure the federal government
governor what do you say to those who
say a society and a civilization can be
measured by how well it treats its
weakest members I would agree with that
and so I think that the changes the
reforms that can come from any of these
programs are fine but you just can't
pull
rug out from under people if they're not
healthy they're not going to work and if
they're not huh if they're hungry
they're not going to go to work so you
have to take care of both of those
things at the same time you're trying to
bring about reform about the number that
he's listing for a drug control 27
billion dollars the big story for most
states now is the opioid epidemic your
state has been greatly affected what do
you make of that number how do you think
the money should be spent on that we
have to spend some money on this
obviously we spend almost a billion
dollars and we've been on this for seven
years and trying to fight this but let
me tell you the bottom line I met with
the drug enforcement agency officials 28
30 32 years they said what do we do let
me tell you it starts in kindergarten
our schools have to be the frontline
mothers and fathers all these you know
mothers and fathers or civic
organizations but the school starting in
kindergarten all the way through the
12th grade have to have a consistent and
constant message to kids stay off the
drugs it'll either kill you you'll end
up in jail and you will lose the purpose
for which the Lord's created you and it
is critical that the schools are the
frontline and engaged in this and
sometimes it's difficult to get them
involved but it is essential if we are
going to win this battle
kindergarten seems so young you're 5
years old you know what six seven years
old you know we can skip with 5 but
there's ways to talk to kids about how
dangerous these things are the same way
we talk to them about the dangers of so
many other things
drugs is it's destroying you know sort
of the culture of our country and we can
we can win this these budgets reflect
the values of a president every every
year and of course as you mentioned
where the budget director yeah right
even as you mentioned Congress Congress
changes things but the budget director
said yesterday this budget we look at
this through the eyes of the people who
are actually paying the bills yeah the
people who pay taxes is that a way to do
a budget no I think you when you do
budgets and look I I went through I was
the chairman of the committee when we
balanced the federal budget the economy
got better but it's a matter of creating
priorities reform is fine privatization
is fine but you cannot just move quickly
to pull the the rug under from people
who need help but at the same time Nora
we have to make sure that we get to the
root of their problems so where does
Congress fall short first of all they
don't permit people to get
Didi's and in as a substitute to the
work requirements you have people don't
know in America you know if you're on
welfare you have to work 30 hours a week
if you get food stamps I actually wrote
this you have to work 20 hours a week
but let's make that work be constructive
so that they can have a future so that
they can have skills so they can get a
job that's what it's all about and the
job training programs offered by the
federal government they're frankly their
I'll say they're pretty much a joke when
it comes to giving people giving States
the flexibility to do what we need to do
to train our people so they have the
skills to work can we talk about the
Manchester attack for a second your
state is known for hosting big events
for instance the Republic I was just at
a rock concert on Friday night with
about 30,000 people a concert just
curious well I went to see the group the
band live which and it was right the
inside garden was supposed to be on
right after that and by the way The Lost
Chris Cornell because of drugs but are
you looking are you looking at different
safety protocols now in light of this
attack whenever we have a concert like
that the Highway Patrol all the security
is out there you know I have two
seventeen year old daughters and they're
very interested in music and got this
just I watched your your coverage this
morning it just broke my heart you know
sometimes we read it in a newspaper
whatever but you see the mothers that
are crying and they don't know where
their children are and are they going to
they know that they're not coming back
but they're holding out hope that
they're in a hospital somewhere look we
can't run away and hi but we have to do
everything that we can do to correct not
protect not just the inside but a little
bit of the perimeter but what I think is
so important is who helped this guy
build this vest we have to track this
down and it means good intelligence and
it means cooperation worldwide and it
also means and I give President Trump
credit for this everybody in this world
is civilized whether you're Christian
Jew Muslim doesn't matter we all have to
stand up and make the argument that this
culture of death of destroying young
people is not acceptable and we must
stop it out and those who sit on the
fence to think about this we have to
pull them over and say you cannot be
somebody that brings tear
to people of all ages in all race and
all gender right Governor Kasich I know
most people agree with that sentiment
thank you very much yes thank you at the
table always good to have you here god
bless them